bernie sanders is now following
the logic of this censorship he says
quote
let's be clear if trump is too dangerous
to send out a tweet or a facebook post
he's too dangerous to be commander in
chief donald trump
must be removed from office immediately
and held accountable for his horrific
acts of sedition
violence and chaos he has not committed
an act of sedition
he has not committed an act of violence
i suppose he has committed acts of chaos
that's kind of why he was elected was to
mix
up the system but the system doesn't
like getting mixed up
listen to the logic though
billionaire oligarch radicals censor the
duly elected sitting president
millionaire radical leftist in the
senate
takes this action as evidence
that trump is if he's too dangerous to
be on twitter
is therefore too dangerous to be
president he must be removed from office
immediately
so if you follow that trail of logic the
reason he must be removed
from office immediately is because the
billionaire radicals say so
do you see how quickly this moves
we got a sensor and we got to kick him
off social media says the oligarch
well if he can't be on social media he
can't be president says the senator
now they try to remove him we're going
to impeach the president says
the speaker of the house and republicans
probably i hope they don't roll over on
impeachment but they'll they'll probably
roll over on something like censure or
something like that this is the way the
regime
works the liberal regime it all works in
accord
the media and technology and the
bureaucracy
and the elected people it all and higher
education it all
works together when are we
going to push back through all legal
channels
grow a spine and go up against the
system
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video